robocalls Tydfil most annoying type of
phone call with every other type of
phone call robo calls are clearly
infuriating every one of us has answered
our phone at some point to hear this hi
this is Josh from the customer service
department can you hear me okay free
medical alert system is a non-bailable
arrest warrant issued under your name
the reason of this call is to inform you
that the IRS is filing lawsuits against
you it was the pause in that last one
that made it a real cliffhanger I mean
you basically knew where it was going
but there was a tantalizing chance that
they were calling people to inform them
that the IRS was filing lawsuit against
Nicolas Cage which you're you assume is
always true but call to confirm every
now and then would be nice the point is
everybody is annoyed by robo calls
hatred of them might be the only thing
that everyone in America agrees on now
and if you've been feeling like you've
been getting more of them recently
you're actually right robo calls
increased by 57% in 2018 to nearly 50
billion calls and it's understandably
pissing people off the plague of robo
calls is getting worse they're the
number one consumer complaint to the
Federal Communications Commission which
receives more than 200,000 protests a
year robo calls make up roughly 60% of
all complaints to the FCC 60% of all
complaints to the FCC are about robo
calls so they are definitely aware of
the problem it's like the actual tea
salon in Vancouver called Netherland but
at this point they definitely know they
have a real issue the only question is
what the are they going to do about
it the nuisance of robo calls has gotten
to the point where even local news
reports about them get interrupted yeah
we can't even get through an interview
without an unwanted phone call I'm
getting a robo call right now as we're
talking as I was preparing this report I
got one it is just not often that a news
report gets interrupted by the subject
of that report is your teenager getting
involved in a strange new sex trend it's
watermelon II and it involves god damn
it can you not do this somewhere else
so tonight tonight let's look at why
robo calls are on the rise and what can
be done about them and let's start with
a basic definition robo calls are any
call where you hear a recording or a
robot voice or when a machine
automatically dialed your number even if
there is a real person on the other end
and while a small percentage of robo
calls may be useful cause about things
like school closings or prescription
reminders the vast majority of them vary
from the irritating to the outright
illegal and you might be surprised to
know how many major companies are
involved in this a list of top Robo
callers includes Capital One Comcast and
Wells Fargo all of whom use robo calls
to chase debts and sometimes they do
that a lot as this woman can testify
librelucha wad never suspected one late
mortgage payment would trigger what she
considers an avalanche of harassment it
came and I just blew me away
lease attorney say they've logged more
than six thousand calls from Wells Fargo
to their client over the last four years
some days such as in January lease says
Wells Fargo rang her more than 20 times
a day that's absolutely ridiculous
because what is the point of calling
someone 20 times a day to collect a debt
oh this is actually great timing because
while I couldn't pay you 45 minutes ago
a small propeller plane full of um
laundered drug money just crashed into
my dam thanks so much for the call you
ravenous ghouls but as you undoubtedly
know it is not just major companies who
do this phone calls are now so cheap and
the technology is so widely available
that just about anyone has the ability
to place a massive number of calls you
created a program here in your life yeah
that's right you're gonna hit a button
and right about now the calls should
start hitting all at once this isn't
saying they're all ringing yeah okay
that's both very impressive and when you
really think about it not actually
that's impressive at all it's basically
the phone electric from the world's
least amusing birthday magician tada
wait nothing well guess what the great
laptop Dini got paid in advance so
all of you
and if you're thinking hold on what
about the Do Not Call list well it still
exists and very occasionally a big
company like Dish Network will get fined
millions for violating it the problem is
though it only applies to one particular
kind of call sales calls and the list
doesn't physically block companies from
calling you it's just something they're
supposed to check before doing so and
scammers generally ignore it first
because they're scammers and second
because it's now easy to conceal their
identity with something called spoofing
and I'll let senator Susan Collins show
you how it works
in the most Awkward possible way my
screen is reading Internal Revenue
Service well let's see
hello this is Susan Collins may I ask
who is calling hello chairman Collins
this is Sam Dewey from your staff are
you calling from the IRS no senator I'm
actually over here
[Applause]
cool you know spoofing is actually the
perfect technology for Susan Collins to
be demonstrating just think about it
it's all about temporarily pretending to
be one thing and then disappointing
everyone when you reveal who you
actually are but but despite sounding
like urban dictionary slang for when
magician's shoot heroin spoofing is
undeniably effective robot callers can
pretend to be calling from your area
increasing the chance that you will pick
up and individual scammers can even
pretend to be someone that you know as
one reporter found out cybersecurity
expert Jim Stickley sets up his phone to
call my mom posing as me hey mom real
quick I need your social security number
I thought some beneficiary forms can you
help me out real quick
I've never there's beneficiary form I
just need to fill it out what's your
cell says kid number real fast great
thanks a lot mom love you
how's it I've got a social security
number holy
literally everything about that was
upsetting from the fact that Jeff Rossen
had someone scam his own mother to the
fact that she fell for it to his amazing
reaction when he realizes that his
mother did something stupid do these
bold choice to broadcast his own mother
stupidity on national television to the
fact that this man just took told
another man's mother that he loves her
too the revelation that he feeds Jeff
Rossen sounds like a middle-aged man
squeezing his own balls
- the fact that Jeff Rossen could really
use a new shirt the point is there's a
lot happening in that clip and none of
it is good also also a quick side note
on that his mother's social security
number wasn't bleeps to protect her
identity
it had to be centered because her social
security number is -
- taint juice ship tits it was no
choice it wasn't her choice blame the
Social Security Administration and
thanks to all these new tactics the
onslaught in scam phone calls is huge
and it's only getting worse
next year some estimates predict half of
all mobile calls will be scam calls
Wow and that is a real problem for
consumers because you have to use your
phone
we can't go back to the days where
everyone would just shout their message
into a jar and then mail that jar across
the country that was a terrible system
and it was only marginally more accurate
than having AT&T now oh you like that
business daddy
Johnny's acting up again Chinese acting
up oh I've been I'm gonna get some spicy
jars in the mail about that so the point
is what can we do about this well on a
personal level you can tell individual
companies you do business with not to
call you by law they're actually not
allowed to robocall your cell without
consent but that is where this gets
tricky because those user agreements
that you agreed to you know the ones
that no one has ever read they often
give companies consent to robocall you
and can make revoking it incredibly
difficult for instance if you're a
customer of credit one bank and you want
them to stop robocalling yourself
just take out your User Agreement and
turn to page four section 19 see where
you'll find that you have to physically
mail them written notice featuring your
name mailing address and the last four
digits of your account number two this P
o box in Nevada and it makes total sense
what you had opted not to do that I
would rather receive a thousand phone
calls a day every day for the rest of my
life then go out and buy a stamp I mean
would I even do that do I have to
go to a post office or gonna just go to
a Walgreens and if I can go to Walgreens
is it all the Walgreens is or just some
and if it's just some how do I find out
which ones call literally call a place
of business with my telephone and ask
them if they could sell me a stamp okay
then what I have to physically walk to
the Walgreens literally physically walk
like with my legs and wait in line and
buy the stamp wat now put it in a
mailbox what the am I gonna find
that mailbox
the only mailboxes I ever see are those
we had boarded up green ones what's the
are those things by the way they're
spooky that's what they are it looks
like a memorial of a pass mailbox that
died in a war
now I have to find the one mailbox in
New York City that hasn't sacrificed its
life in this country pry open its big
hungry male mouth and shove a stamped
envelope down its dusty throat none of
that's gonna happen I'd rather die than
engage in that nonsense and deep down I
think you know that
so so it is no wonder that some people
choose to simply mess with robocallers
as one journalist did when he noticed
the person on the other end sounded a
bit suspicious well I'm calling about an
online request you once made about
health insurance coverage okay with all
major companies incomparable hey are you
a robot what will you tell me you're not
a robot just say I'm not a robot please
I am a real person I mean I believe you
but will you just say I'm not a robot
it'll make me feel better to hear you
say if you could say the words I'm not a
robot it would really mean a lot to me I
am a real person can you hear me okay
right but will you say I'm not a robot
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that man is dead now she killed him she
stole his skin she walks among us and
she'll kill again well as far as that is
experts advise you not to engage with
robocalls at all don't pick up and don't
talk if you do answer because that lets
them know that yours is a live number
and you'll just get robo calls more but
the much bigger point here is it should
not entirely be up to us to deal with
this the FCC has the authority
to police robo calls and a few years
back they actually put some guardrails
in place with a set of rules designed to
limit them as the FCC's former chair
explained at the time they they
basically followed a simple principle
the consumer needs to be the one who's
in charge the consumer needs to give
consent that they want to be called or
if they are called and haven't given
consent to remove that consent by saying
don't call me anymore or by calling
their phone company and saying I don't
want to get these calls and that sounds
completely reasonable but unfortunately
those rules were then struck down after
a trade group sued at which point robo
calls increased significantly so we made
real progress toward addressing a
problem but then we blew it we basically
got our one year sobriety chip then
celebrated by drinking a gallon of
Captain Morgan which is not to say that
there aren't things that the FCC could
do unfortunately their current chair is
this guy at G PI you've probably seen
him on this show before alongside his
stupid mark and by the way Cheers cheers
for you pi says a lot of the right
things about this he said that robo
calls are the scourge of civilization
and he's had a little too much fun
showing how dedicated he is to tackling
this issue to borrow from former
President Kennedy let every robot caller
know whether it wishes us well or ill
and we shall pay any price bear any
burden meet any hardship support any
solution and oppose any but to assure
the survival and the peace of American
consumers it sounds like I may have just
won a cruise if you'll excuse me I have
to take the skull but thank you very
much mr. chairman
ladies and gentlemen that man is a
goober and as you probably have
aspirations for a high political office
but I would argue that that's not gonna
work out for him because Americans can
have and will elect bastards morons
blowhards crooks perverts con
men scumbags and shitweasels but they
will never ever elect a goober but while
he talks a good game pie actually
opposed those rules that we mentioned
earlier and was extremely happy when
they were overturned and since becoming
FCC chair he has seemed too reluctant to
force telecoms to act for instance he
could require them to offer free call
blocking services or implement something
called call authentication which could
significantly curtail spoofing but he
hasn't done that instead what he's done
is urge them to do it and while some say
that they are working on it the fact is
if he had required them to do it from
the get-go we might actually have those
fixes by now because telecom companies
aren't really gonna listen to you unless
you force them to and AT&T isn't going
to listen to you at all unless you call
them on t-mobile how will they hear
otherwise their call would drop out
that's right business tapping oh that's
right you've inherited a problem child
let's ask let's dance you and I but the
thing experts are really worried that PI
might do is bow to pressure from groups
like telemarketers and banks and draft a
new narrower definition of what
constitutes autodialing it's technical
but that would basically limit what
would count as a robo call and if he
does that it could have huge
consequences so for instance if Wells
Fargo called your cellphone 6,000 times
you might no longer be able to sue them
under anti Robo call laws and it is safe
to assume that at that point robo calls
are going to increase even more so if
only there was a way to get the FCC's
attention on this issue of course I mean
what one way to do that would be if
someone had I don't know say the office
numbers of all five FCC commissioners
because then you could hypothetically
set up a program to robocall those
numbers every 90 minutes with a message
say I don't know like this high FCC this
is John from customer service
congratulations you've just won a chance
to lower robo calls in America today
sorry but I am a live person robo calls
are incredibly annoying and the person
who can stop them is you talk to you
again in 90 minutes is a bagpipe music
that would be really annoying right to
get that every 90 minutes it would
really drive the point home and nope I
guess at this point it's probably
obvious what is about to happen here yes
FCC we meet again old friends except
this time unlike our past encounters I
don't actually need to ask hoards of
real people to bombard you with messages
because with the miracle of Robo calling
I can now do it all by myself you see it
turns out Robo calling is so easy it
only took our tech guy literally 15
minutes to work out how to do it so when
I press this button will it trigger our
robo calls to the FCC no no that that
would be too simple instead behold what
instead when my finger presses this
button it will trigger this much larger
finger that will press a much larger
button which will trigger our calls to
the FCC so FCC you know what you need to
do and by the way if you wanted to if
you want to tell us that you don't
consent to be Robo called that's
absolutely no problem just write a
certified letter to the address that
we've buried somewhere within the first
chapter of Moby Dick
that's currently scrolling up the screen
you've got that right you got it find
the address write us a letter and we'll
stop the calls immediately and if you're
thinking that there should be a simpler
way to opt out well no okay there's
simply no point delaying this any longer
here goes unleash hell
it's raining
for you that's our show
Oh
[Applause]